sono uomo
sono diverso da mia sorella che è donna
è un problema
no
forse lo è più per lei in Italia visto
che è ancora qualche piccolo problemino
sulla parità di genere ce lo abbiamo
sono bianco
sono diverso da Papis il mio amico del
Senegal
è un problema
No forse anche in questo caso lo è più
per lui in Italia
sono omosessuale
sono diverso dalla maggior parte dei
miei amici che sono eterosessuali o
almeno così sembra così si professano
è un problema
finocchio
Recchia [__]
[__] che capezza che caspanca
Dai ancora
[__] [__] rotto in culo
Colpito e affondato
Beh
non so cosa pensate voi
ma per me è un problema c'è
c'è
stato ci sarà
forse anche dopo questo Talk professore
della scuola italiana che parla
pubblicamente della propria
omosessualità lo scandalo
le cose meglio tenersi per sé Perché è
una alle 4:20 Questo era una cosa che
diceva sempre mia madre
mia madre
Io non sono mai stato un attivista lgbt
forse non lo sono nemmeno oggi non mi
considero tale però credo che a volte
sia importante con i giusti tempi le
giuste modalità
imparare un po' a metterci la faccia
Anche semplicemente raccontando un po'
la propria esperienza personale
perché forse anche questo vuol dire un
po' essere attivisti
ed è per questo che oggi vorrei tornare
un po' indietro nel tempo
Alla fine degli anni 90 inizi degli anni
2000 quando un adolescente di 14/15 anni
ad Ancona
iniziava a fare i conti con la propria
omosessualità
per fardello
bravo a scuola
rispettoso delle regole in casa è fuori
casa
preciso ordinato un bravo figlio Bravo
nipote bravo amico bravo studente bravo
bravo bravo
Eppure
c'era lei
quella bella macchiolina nera
quel segreto che mi portavo dentro e che
speravo tanto non ci fosse
Quel pacco bomba come lo Chiamai un
quarto superiore per un progetto di arte
che minacciava di esplodere e rovinare
tutto quanto
quanto gli altri sapranno di me
nessuno mi vorrà più bene
mi allontaneranno tutti devo imparare a
cavarmela da solo
Questo è quello che mi ripetevo sempre
Fortunatamente non era vero Non è andata
così La vita mi ha smentito ma all'epoca
chi lo sapeva
potersi tornare indietro andrei da quel
ragazzino spaventato gli farei un bel
pappazzo la spalla e gli arriva
tranquillo che alla fine non andrà così
male come pensi
poi arriva il primo pc le prime
connessioni di internet lente lentissime
con quei vecchi modem che facevano un
rumore infernale che siete collegati a
Internet si collegava al telefono di
casa
Eppure la rete ha aperto nuovi scenari
nuovi mondi nuove possibilità
primo Tra tutto quello di metterti in
contatto con altri ragazzi come te
che intendo di poterli conoscere
incontrare avere dei primi appuntamenti
dello bellissimo emozionante
anche si rimaneva un poco il pizzico di
amarezza nel vedere i tuoi amici i tuoi
compagni che conoscevano ragazze e
ragazze da frequentare in discoteca per
il corso nei pub mentre tu lì costretto
a questa ricerca online segreta nascosto
dietro a uno schermo dietro a un
computer dietro un nickname
Ma poi a 17 anni arriva la prima storia
importante
il primo innamoramento Le prime
esperienze di intimità Le prime
esperienze sessuali una meraviglia una
gioia immensa
non ne parli con nessuno
perché hai paura di come gli altri
possano reagire
addirittura sul cellulare salvo il nome
differente perché hai paura che possono
prenderti il telefono e leggere i
messaggi
un nome di donna si intende
assurdo vero Eppure è andato proprio
così Pietro che magicamente diventa Sara
quando sei in giro con lui non te la
senti di andare a mano per la mano e si
muovete scambiare un gesto di tenerezza
Un bacio State bene Attenti ad andare in
posti nascosti dove nessuno vi vede
perché hai paura del giudizio degli
altri di quello che possono dire delle
offese magari anche delle aggressioni
fisiche
A me fortunatamente non è mai successo
ma la paura c'era e non credo perché
fossi ad essere un fifone Ma perché a
livello socio-culturale una coppia
omosessuale non era e non è ancora oggi
vista come una coppia eterosessuale
Mi verrebbe da chiedere a una coppia
formata da un ragazzo da una ragazza da
un uomo una donna
Ma voi vi siete mai nascosti per darvi
un bacio
Vi è mai capitato di avere paura per un
vostro gesto di tenerezza che vi siete
scambiati che vi potesse mettere in
pericolo questa cosa
Io non credo se fosse successo mi
dispiacerebbe per voi perché non
dovrebbe accadere
così come non dovrebbe accadere di
mentire ai propri genitori ai propri
amici ai propri parenti solo perché
siamo una persona che non corrisponde a
quello che a livello sociale è
maggiormente accettato
Io ho passato tantissimi anni a
nascondermi
ad avere paura non parlare di me di
quello che sentivo di quello che vivevo
anni Preziosi della mia vita che nessuno
Nessuno mi darà mai più indietro
ho perso mio nonno
una persona per me fondamentale
prima che potessi dirgli che fosse
realmente
e anche questo nessuno me lo darà mai
più indietro
E comunque vorrei tornare anche sulla
parola persona perché prima lo un po'
enfatizzata Infatti tantissime volte mi
è capitato di dire ho conosciuto una
persona
mi piace una persona Domani esco con una
persona che a dirlo così sembra quasi
ridicolo Ma tante volte usare questa
parola Invece di dire ragazzo è stato
per me uno scudo protettivo potentissimo
solo molti anni dopo un Erasmus un mio
amico brasiliano mi fece notare Ma
perché usi la parola persona
ridicolo effettivamente
io forse non sono stato coraggiosissimo
Non ho avuto il coraggio di espormi
pubblicamente Quando ero ragazzo ma
sicuramente essere adolescente agli
inizi del 2000 ad Ancona non è stato
facile essere omosessuale in una città
così piccola
una ventina d'anni fa
oggi Pur essendoci ancora tanti tabù
tantissimi sociali credo che la
situazione sia leggermente migliorata
sicuramente si può fare ancora tanto di
più però vedo attorno a me tutti gli
adolescenti che
vivono un pochino più serenamente
tranquillamente il proprio orientamento
sessuale ma soprattutto ci sono loro sui
televisione
su Netflix si vedono tantissime serie TV
tantissimi programmi dove abbiamo storie
di omosessualità di bisessualità di
coppie
aperte di Poli amore di non binarismo e
soprattutto vengono sempre presentate
all'interno di una pluralità di
situazioni legate alla sfera affettiva
relazionale sessuale che quando ero
ragazzo io non c'erano Quando ero
ragazzo io c'era solo lui
Dawson Creek
con il mitico Jack mcfit che sicuramente
è stato il personaggio con cui mi sono
identificato ed era l'unico ma prima ad
arrivare a dare un bacio a un altro
ragazzo sono adesso tipo sei stagioni
che adesso forse sei No ma duravano
un'eternità rispetto a quelli di oggi di
Netflix
Comunque sto Forse sto divagando vorrei
tornare un po' al punto iniziale del
discorso
sono uomo
bianco
mediamente alto
docente di matematica fisica omosessuale
Queste sono alcune delle mie
caratteristiche
così come le prime vengono generalmente
recepite senza particolari
sconvolgimenti turbamenti Non vedo
perché debba essere diverso per l'ultima
PayPal essere questo Fonte per me di
disagio di imbarazzo di vergogna e
potenzialmente per mano di altri possa
essere fonte di giudizio di offesa di
aggressione
non tutti sanno che io sono un
insegnante perché non è detto che tutti
vanno a saperlo come non tutti sanno che
sono omosessuale perché non è detto che
quando io conosco una persona sia una
cosa che emerga sempre ma così come mi
sentirei sufficientemente tranquillo a
parlare della mia professione
allo stesso modo vorrei sentirmi
sufficientemente tranquillo nel parlare
del mio orientamento sessuale
e allora mi sono chiesto Vabbè Andrea ma
tu cosa puoi fare
io posso continuare a lavorare su me
stesso per cercare di essere più
coraggioso per togliermi questo
imbarazzo questo disagio come sto
facendo anche in questo momento su
questo palco
però ho detto ma forse anche gli altri
possono fare qualcosa ho pensato e ho
detto sì forse anche gli altri anche le
altre persone potrebbero aiutare in
qualche modo a tutti quelle persone come
me omosessuali ma anche le altre
minoranze
discriminate penso che forse possano
provare
a non giudicare
a non indicare
a non schernire Non insultare non
offendere non aggredire
ma piuttosto
ad aprirsi
ad avvicinarsi
a capire
ad accettare
così che la società forse può diventare
veramente accogliente nei confronti
diverso
Ma che poi
ma diverso da chi
[Musica]
[Applauso]